it's been five years since elon musk
first showed off tesla's solar roof
tiles you want to call your neighbors
over and say check up check out the
sweet roof
yet five years later they are far from
mainstream unlike tesla's other offering
of large solar panels these tiles are
made to look like normal roofing
shingles that generate electricity for
your home getting into the business of
making them was controversial tesla
shareholders sued musk for buying the
solar panel company founded by his
cousins solarcity for 2.6 billion
alleging it amounted to a bailout for
his family he was also the largest
shareholder so musk bet big on these
tiles but their deployment has fallen
from the highs of 2017 although it
appears to be picking up recently tesla
notes 2021 saw a 68 increase in
megawatts deployed year over year
although tesla claimed it could
manufacture a thousand solar tile roofs
a week bloomberg reported that the
company could barely manage 200 weekly
installs i've reached out to tesla for
the latest figures but i haven't heard
back turns out it's been much harder to
install the roofs than tesla imagined we
are choked at the installation point
we basically made some significant
mistakes in in assessing the difficulty
of certain roofs the complexity of roofs
varies dramatically so you just can't
have a one-size-fits-all situation tesla
installs some roofs itself and at other
times relies on third-party installers
so the big thing with tesla solar roof
is the complexity factor cj mcconaughey
is the owner of three tree roofing a
certified tesla roof installer in the
seattle area the plans that we get that
we design for the roof it looks like a
lego kit just like a lego set all the
pieces have to fit together perfectly
the wiring is also very complex because
this isn't something that we deal with
with any other kind of roof dealing with
the tiles handling them because it's
glass they're also pretty slippery
there's just a lot more moving pieces to
this type of roofing than a traditional
roof so for traditional roof like the
one most people have takes for example
three days to install how much longer
would it take to install a tesla solar
roof well that's a great question
um if it's a
you know moderate to easy roof design
the tesla solar roof is going to be more
like the 10 to 12 days given the
unforeseen complexities tesla hiked the
prices of its roofs which really upset
customers and got slapped with a
class-action lawsuit in california last
year led by a customer who said his
contract increased from 71 000 to a
whopping
146 000. tesla then told customers
attorneys that it would reverse the hike
for those who had already signed
contracts so how much could you expect
to pay for one of these roofs right now
that depends on many factors where you
live the size of your home its age as an
example tesla's order page shows a 2 000
square foot home in las vegas with an
average electricity bill of 135 dollars
a month is estimated to cost 57 300
before the federal tax credit tesla
notes the price can vary up to 12
depending on complexity to try to entice
more people to choose their roofs tesla
recently announced a 20-year loan option
so customers can pay for their system
over time a big reason tesla hasn't done
more to boost its solar business is
because its primary focus is on mass
producing electric cars tesla went
through hell in 2018 trying to churn out
its most affordable car yet the model 3.
so it was all hands on deck to crank out
as many cars as possible and solar took
a back seat we have to basically take
the whole company
people that were on solar and have work
on cars not only did tesla divert staff
it also fired solar executives bloomberg
reported that musk dismissed both the
head of tesla energy rj johnson and ryan
nungesser the director of operations at
tesla's buffalo factory where the tiles
are made and now the focus is on model y
production at two new giga factories in
texas and berlin even with so much on
its plate tesla likely won't give up on
its solar ambitions because it's a way
to show the world that it's more than a
car company but one that intends to lead
the transition to clean energy and i
hope you agree that's the future we won
solar is an integral part of its clean
energy ecosystem the energy produced
from the roof is stored in the tesla
power wall which can power your home
during an outage or charge your electric
car so it's a three it's an obvious
three-part solution except two parts are
still missing not only the solar tiles
but also power wall production has
lagged behind which musk blames on chip
shortages due to the pandemic tesla
acknowledges its solar division has work
to do it wrote in its fourth quarter
earnings report that it plans on making
further cost improvements it appears to
be moving in that direction tesla has
launched an updated solar roof tile with
a 23 higher power capacity without
increasing the size of the tile
according to a spec sheet obtained by
electric so fewer solar tiles would be
needed since each roof uses a mix of
tiles some with and some without solar
cells although they all look the same
fewer solar tiles means fewer electrical
connections which can bring down the
cost although tesla's solar roofs have
yet to take off musk says he's confident
it will happen i think it will not be
long before tesla is by far the market
leader in solar
so i've been looking for an exciting
investment for 2022 and a revolutionary
platform offers one that really caught
my eye masterworks dot io masterworks
gives you the chance to invest in famous
paintings by picasso monet and banksy by
buying shares in their artworks why art
art has outpaced the s p 500 from 1995
to 2021 and has almost no correlation
with stocks is it legit yes it is
masterworks is the first company to
offer paintings filled with the
securities and exchange commission as
public offerings is anyone else doing it
yes they are over 300 000 investors have
already signed up one of their latest
offerings by banksy sold out in under
three hours masterworks flipped another
painting by the famous street artist for
a 32 return in 2020 and george condo's
staring into space gave investors a 31
return last year there's a lot of demand
to invest in art and often a waiting
list but you can get priority access by
heading to my custom link in the
description which also supports this
channel thanks for watching for news
think i'm cindy palm